Rihanna's ex Chris Brown dropped a
surprise track last night just 24 hours
after he was arrested meanwhile there
are new questions about his accuser
you're not doing this for the fame or
anything this is real you're not lying
this is what happened to you and this is
what happened to me but be thrown beauty
queen bailey kern may be undone by some
incriminating text that one report says
are in the hands of browns attorney Mark
Geragos allegedly sent to a friend early
Tuesday morning
Chris Brown is kicking me out of his
house because I called his friend
jewelry fake can you come get me he was
there in the kitchen area showcasing his
diamonds so of course I'm like oh pretty
current allegedly went on to text that
if she couldn't get picked up quote I'm
going to set him up and call the cops
and say he tried to shoot me and that
will teach him a lesson about ten
minutes later the 911 dispatcher was
sending police for the location to
female I know crying and asking for help
Bailey did tell us she ran away from the
house and hid under a truck with her
friend we hid like against the tires
literally underneath the truck I am
terrified are they gonna shoot me on the
street by 8:30 in the morning Brown's
house was surrounded by police there
were soon reports that Chris had
barricaded himself inside Brown was
quickly on Instagram to protest and
declare his innocence barricaded myself
in my house have you seen my house
that's kind of what Browns friend Ray J
who was also there told me how can we
barricade ourselves in Chris's houses
10,000 square feet a few hours later
Brown was arrested for suspicion of
assault with a deadly weapon then
released on bail it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous God will stop playing with me
like I'm I'm the villain out here like
I'm going crazy I'm not